bienvenue pour le journal de la
rédaction de tvfils 78 nous sommes le
vendredi 7 novembre et dans cette
édition il sera question des frontières
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines pour les
prochaines années une question qui
divise les élus parfois même au sein de
leur propre famille politique et
change-t-on du lors de la dernière
séance du conseil d'agglomération hier
soir un forum sur l'écho habitats pour
construire et rénover son logement en
limitant sa facture énergétique et une
démonstration de vélo assistance
électrique c'est à jouer un Josas samedi
nous en parlerons avec un autre invité
Thierry ordin gérant de la société
néo-veclec et comme chaque vendredi
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
du procès de cet homme de 37 ans accusé
du meurtre de son fils à l'abandon du
projet eskidom à Élancourt
et puis cette autre fait divers dans
l'actualité yvelinoise un boucher de
Trappes d'une trentaine d'années a été
placée en examen rapporte le quotidien
Le Parisien la justice lui reproche
d'avoir porté et début septembre dans sa
boutique un violent ou de hachoir sur
son apprenti qui lui réclamait le
paiement de son salaire un coup
entraînant 75 jours d'incapacité totale
de travail le suspect parle d'une
tentative d'extorsion de fond et de
légitime défense seulement des témoins
présents ce jour-là sur que l'ex
apprenti n'était ni armé ni menaçant la
police a aussi découvert que le boucher
employé plusieurs sans-papiers en
conseil communautaire à 50 ans en
Yvelines les élus étaient appelés à
statuer jeudi soir sur la proposition du
préfet de région proposant un
élargissement de l'agglomération à 800
000 habitants incluant donc d'autres
établissements publics de l'Essonne ou
encore de Versailles Grand Parc si les
élus de droite comme de gauche sont tous
d'accord pour s'opposer à cette
importance élargissement ils ne sont en
revanche pas du tout contre une fille
qui ont du mal par contre à se mettre
d'accord sur la vision du futur 50 ans
en Yvelines Catherine zulato
demain les intercommunalités devront
compter plus de 200 000 habitants 50 ans
en Yvelines doverra s'élargir mais vers
où tout l'enjeu du débat qui s'est
déroulé ce jeudi soir lors du conseil
communautaire si les élus de droite
comme de gauche ne veulent pas de la
proposition du préfet de région de
passer à 800000 habitants il y a sur ce
sujet un réel consensus les périmètres
d'élargissement sont loin très loin de
faire l'unanimité pour le groupe
majoritaire la solution est à l'ouest de
l'agglomération je souhaite que on
puisse aller d'une part vers des
communes et vers une intervenir qui
souhaite nous rejoindre en l'occurrence
la communauté de communes de l'Ouest
parisien composé de plaisir les blés
vilebreux le maire de Maurepas actuel a
confirmé aussi la volonté de la Ville de
Maurepas de nous rejoindre et j'estime
aussi même si la ville de Coignières
aujourd'hui n'a pas manifesté son envie
de nous rejoindre j'estime que là il y a
une continuité de territoire et aussi me
paraît déjà un effort important pour la
communauté d'agglomération qui décomposé
que de cette commune et les maires de
gauche de faire leur contre-proposition
pour un développement cette fois à l'Est
nous souhaitons nous conserver un rôle
de pionnier à cette agglomération en
proposant une alliance à la cape en
Essonne qui s'attendent bien à les mêmes
enjeux en termes de mobilité en terme de
développement économique en terme
universitaire d'abord il y a évidemment
cette alliance entre la cape et la
casquette mais si Maurepas et Coignières
le souhaitent évidemment pourquoi pas
nous ne sommes pas opposés mais là
encore il faut que tout ça est une
cohérence qui a un projet de territoire
et le projet de territoire il est sur le
périmètre de l'opération internationale
une ouverture vers le plateau de Saclay
le groupe majoritaire ne dit pas non
mais sous une autre forme que celle de
l'intercommunalité c'est possible mais
dans le cas d'une coopération pas d'une
fusion et c'est pour ça que ce soir j'ai
proposé que ce soit créé un pôle
métropolitain au terme d'une heure de
débat ponctuée par une suspension de
séances les élus ont unanimement dit non
à une agglomération à 800 000 habitants
la proposition
d'élargissement du groupe majoritaire a
été adopté quant à la position des
maires de gauche Michel Ogier a assuré
qu'elle figurait dans le compte-rendu
adressé au préfet de région le 21
décembre prochain la commission
régionale de coopération intercommunale
doit se réunir pour examiner l'ensemble
des avis rendus par les élus vivinois
début 2015 un projet devrait être
présenté pour une mise en œuvre rapide
au 1er janvier 2016
l'Union des étudiants communistes à
organiser une réunion publique également
jeudi soir à l'université de
Saint-Quentin autour de la mise en place
d'une politique d'austérité dans
l'établissement d'après ses étudiants
les coupes budgétaires du gouvernement
dans les services publics entraverait la
qualité de leur formation ils souhaitent
à terme organiser un référendum sur
cette question leurs explications au
micro de yolent Torres cette austérité
se manifeste déjà principalement par des
suppressions de télé aussi des
suppressions de filières ainsi que par
le nombre renouvellement des
connaissances au niveau de la
bibliothèque universitaire puisque la
fac a décidé de ne plus renouveler les
livres
c'est que sur une restriction de ses
horaires d'ouverture
à terme c'est aussi tout simplement la
dévalorisation des diplômes des
étudiants nous réclame en fait une
rallonge budgétaire de la part de l'État
parce que l'UVSQ c'est pas université
c'est pas un cas isolé en fait il y a 23
universités au total qui sont difficiles
budgétaires donc ces clients un vrai
problème de dotation de la part de
l'État donc voilà une rallonge
budgétaire pour pouvoir réinvestir dans
nos formations et puisque l'on parle de
l'Université de 50 ans en Yvelines
sachez qu'un magazine américain l'a fait
figuré en bonne place dans un classement
mondial des meilleurs établissements du
supérieur l'UVSQ arrive 14e université
sur les 18 universités françaises
présentes dans ce palmarès ce qui en
fait selon US News and World Report le
383e établissement post-bac au niveau
mondial le 168e au niveau européen
éducation toujours et les nouveaux
rythmes scolaires après consultation des
acteurs éducatifs de la ville la
municipalité de Bois-d'Arcy a décidé de
procéder à quelques ajustements à
compter du 17 novembre la pause
méridienne sera donc avancée d'un quart
d'heure de 11h45 à 14h en lui et place
de midi à 14h15 et puis les rythmes
scolaires il en était justement question
dans notre dernier 7 8 société mardi sur
cette antenne Catherine zelato recevait
des élus pour un état des lieux depuis
septembre
en un mot cette réforme c'est du plus ou
du moins ou en attente de voir je pense
que c'est du plus par expérience à la
réussite éducative c'est un complément
sur le territoire de Trappes en tout cas
à Montigny j'espère que ça le sera je
suis très heureuse de voir tout le mal
que se donne ce qui interviennent auprès
des enfants et puis on va voir pardon et
qui seront récompensés
les résultats scolaires il faut changer
la pédagogie en France ou la rendre
beaucoup plus interactive beaucoup le
parti vis-à-vis il faut changer le
contenu des programmes et surtout la
formation des profs qu'il faut renforcer
les rythmes scolaires c'est complètement
dépassé c'est obsolète
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas en tout cas
il faut que ça s'inscrive dans la durée
et puis on verra à mon avis dans cinq
ans
on reviendrait dans 5 ans
inefficace coûteuse et surtout elle ne
prend pas en compte le rythme biologique
des enfants c'est à dire que la vraie
réforme qui aura été de réduire les
vacances scolaires et bien elle n'a pas
été faite parce que comme d'habitude le
gouvernement reculé
samedi oui novembre forum de l'écho
habitat à Jouy-en-Josas à la salle du
vieux marché vous allez apprendre à
construire à rénover votre logement pour
faire des économies d'énergie et surtout
préserver l'environnement cela va
débuter à 11h jusqu'à 18h des exposants
locaux des architectes professionnels
aussi seront présents avec des
conseillers financiers car tout cela a
un coût à l'Agence Locale de l'énergie
de 50 ans sera sur place et puis ce sera
aussi l'occasion d'essayer les vélos à
assistance électrique celui de la
société néo-vellec de Magny-les-Hameaux
et bonsoir Thierry ordiness bonsoir
bienvenue au plateau vous êtes le gérant
donné au Velec un mot sur le forum déjà
comment vous vous êtes retrouvé sur
cette programmation jouer dans un
Jouy-en-Josas ce 8 novembre et bien tout
simplement parce que la commune de Jouy
m'a invité récemment à participer à ce
forum parce que
l'éco-comportement ce n'est pas que les
cohabitats mais aussi l'écomobilité et
parce que le VAC est sans électric
s'inscrit bien aujourd'hui dans le
déplacement urbain en l'occurrence mais
pas que ça puisque aujourd'hui il existe
des vélos assistance électrique de tout
type pas compris VTT VTC et comme je le
disais avant urbain on va détailler un
petit peu justement ces vélos
électriques mais en tant que gérant
justement que cette société vous êtes
équat ou même vous avez aménagé votre
logement ou alors de réflexion globale
est-ce que vous aussi vous l'appliquez
tout à fait bien sûr puisque nous avons
travaillé sur l'isolation de notre
maison lorsque nous l'avons acheté
puisqu'il s'agit d'une ancienne maison
donc il y avait des choses à faire et
puis le système de chauffage aujourd'hui
qui est adapté donc c'est un mode de
pensée global le transport le logement
on en vient à ces vélos assistance
électrique comment ça fonctionne un VAE
vélo assistance électrique c'est d'abord
un vélo donc il ne faut pas imaginer que
c'est une mobylette ça ne fonctionne pas
tout seul il faut d'abord pédaler mais
lorsqu'on vous avez un moteur qui
fait la même chose que vous qui vous
aide à avancer et ce moteur peut
produire jusqu'à 400 fois votre effort
de de pédalage donc autant dire que une
côte aujourd'hui n'est plus un problème
avec un vélo à 600 électrique quelle
utilisation pour les VAE est-ce qu'on
peut faire des longs trajets à quelle
vitesse oui aujourd'hui les vélos
deviennent de plus en plus performants
les en termes de technologie sont
fulgurantes merci au téléphone portable
et à la portabilité des ordinateurs ou
de l'électroportatif aujourd'hui on
atteint sur des vélos très performants
comme des vélos de SEV par exemple des
autonomies qui dépassent les 100 km
d'autonomie donc autant dire que on peut
faire de longs trajets donc la crainte
de la plupart de tomber en panne sèche
au bout de 5 10 km
n'a pas de fondement sauf peut-être il
reste encore mal malheureusement sur le
marché des produits de qualité
relativement médiocre il y a différents
types de vélos à assistance électrique
vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure il y
a certains il y a une classification
c'est 250 watts de puissance maximum
pour les VAE après on change de
catégorie tout à fait donc en dessous de
150 watts ça reste du vélo donc aucune
obligation légale puisque ça reste du
vélo d'immatriculer d'avoir une carte
grise une assurance responsabilité
civile etc etc on reste dans le vélo et
la liberté du vélo d'où l'intérêt du VAE
puisque vous n'avez aucun frais si ce
n'est d'acheter ce vélo et de
l'entretenir bien évidemment évidemment
mais aucun frais de parking la liberté
du vélo voilà le coup ça coûte cher
justement
le coût moyen du vélo assistance
électrique et de l'ordre de 1800 euros à
peu près sachant qu'on a aujourd'hui des
produits qui sont très performants et
durables la tendance va encore sur une
augmentation durabilité de performance
dans les années à venir il y a une durée
de vie de combien d'années pour ces
vélos bien évidemment la durée de vie
est infinie comme votre vieux vélo
Peugeot vous avez été peut-être de votre
grand-père la seule le seul élément qui
a une durée de vie limite c'est la
batterie qui vieillit dès lors qu'elle a
sort de l'usine de fabrication elle perd
en capacité tout au long de sa vie la
durée de vie moyenne sera peut-être aux
alentours de 5 ans sur des batteries 5-7
ans sur des batteries Lithium Polymère
lithium pour ceux qui voudrait investir
ça ensuite on peut changer cette pièce
on peut changer la batterie et garder le
vélo tout à fait tout à fait les
batteries sont complètement démontables
interchangeables elles sont extrêmement
facilement démontables puisqu'on peut la
recharger à son domicile lorsqu'on
habite en appartement on peut la charger
laisser le vélo en bas monter avec la
batterie et ce sont des éléments il faut
une prise et là ça devient plus
compliqué dans les appartements sur les
parkings communs alors que voilà par
rapport par rapport aux maisons avec les
VAE vous n'aurez pas ce type de problème
double avantage pour l'environnement
pour le porte-monnaie aussi à l'usage ça
coûte ça coûte rien alors pour le
portefeuille effectivement en terme de
consommation il faut savoir qu'un vélo
assistance électrique consomme
l'équivalent de 1 euro d'électricité
pour 1000 km autant vous dire que
l'investissement en vaut la chandelle
pour celui qui décide et c'est quasiment
la moitié de ma clientèle aujourd'hui de
faire le pas d'acheter un vélo
assistance électrique certains
investissements ont départ est important
puisque le coût est quand même important
mais la rentabilité de ce type de
transport est évidente au delà bien sûr
du plaisir de faire du vélo du plaisir
d'aller au travail à vélo sans
transpirer à l'aller je mets
l'assistance maximum puisque c'est
complètement modulable au retour je veux
faire un peu de sport je réduis mon
assistance voire je la coupe vous avez
total liberté sur les vélos assistance
électrique de moduler cette puissance
d'assistance vous faites ce que vous
voulez vous proposez vos solutions pour
les particulier ce sera le cas demain
sur le rendez-vous du forum à Jouy mais
aussi pour les entreprises les
collectivités tout à fait alors
néovellec c'est en fait bien plus que
d'acheter un vélo assistance électrique
mais au Vélo propose toute une gamme de
services effectivement aussi bien en
particulier aux entreprises que
collectivités sous forme de vente
classique traditionnelle mais
personnalisation de vélo assistance
électrique et surtout de services de
proximité à domicile pardon ou sur site
pour les entreprises nouvelle ex se
déplace le principe de néolex est d'être
disponible flexible et mobile
contrairement à une boutique mais on a
le sentiment que votre activité se
développe et se développe plutôt bien
vous vous êtes lancé quand dans cette
dans cette branche tout à fait donc je
me suis lancé en début d'année en fait
ma société relativement récente je mène
mon activité depuis huit mois maintenant
avec un grand succès j'ai pu vérifier au
travers en particulier du grand public
l'engouement du en France sachant
qu'aujourd'hui la part modale du vélo au
sens large du vélo en France n'est que
de 3% si nous regardons nos voisins
également autrichien Suisse sans parler
des Pays-Bas la part modale est
d'environ 20% dans les grandes villes de
ces pays là on monte jusqu'à 50%
Amsterdam tout le monde connaît beaucoup
de gens connaissent Amsterdam les vélos
sont partout donc une marge de
progression importante effectivement
aujourd'hui il y a énormément de
demandes il y a un besoin important à
tel point que les industriels ont un
petit peu de mal à suivre la demande et
vous pourrez les tester ces vélos demain
notamment à jouer les renseignements qui
sont affichés à l'écran une dernière
question vous allez leur dire quoi
justement au public pour être séduit
parce que le froid revient la pluie
revient c'est plus difficile à
convaincre de faire du vélo même s'il
est assistant électrique sur l'hiver
c'est l'un des freins pour la plupart de
mes de mes concitoyens faire du vélo
alors qu'il fait qu'il pleut ou qu'il
fait froid
je leur tendance à les conseiller de
regarder un peu nos voisins allemands
suisses néerlandais danois dans la
parbonnade est extrêmement importante du
vélo la pratique est extrêmement
importante qu'est-ce qu'ils font les
équipes bien donc nouvelle aussi propose
des équipements des vestes des casques
des gants adaptés au cyclisme
complètement adapté aux cyclisme merci
d'être passé en plateau vous retrouve
donc sur le forum de l'écho habitat
samedi à jouer avec ses vélos assistance
électrique Merci à VOUS 10 novembre à
partir de 11 heures
on en revient à présent comme chaque
semaine à l'essentiel de l'actualité
depuis lundi on commence par ce coup de
froid jeté sur le projet skido mardi et
la piste de ce qui couverte et qu'il
devait être réalisé sur la colline
Descours et maintenant plus d'actualité
il est pas question qu'on expose
aujourd'hui les finances de la casquille
à cette expérience là donc quand l'État
réouvrira les vannes on redémarrera ce
projet on fait pas des promesses on
n'engage pas des gens si on n'a pas
l'équilibre budgétaire dès le départ
c'était mardi soir sur TVfil 78 le
vice-président en charge des finances à
l'agglomération maire d'Élancourt
annonçait l'arrêt du projet ski-dom sur
sa ville un projet qui devait voir le
jour au sommet de la colline point
culminant de l'Île-de-France et pourtant
défendu ardemment ces dernières semaines
ça sert à rien de son balai sur un
projet qui de date pas dit à quelques
jours qui date déjà depuis plusieurs
années ça fait plusieurs années déjà que
les équipes les anciennes majorités
d'ailleurs de la communauté
ont travaillé sur des projets
d'aménagement de la colline le skiddle
aussi n'est pas arrivé comme ça par
enchantement ça fait aussi plusieurs
années que l'on en parle ce qui est
clair c'est qu'avec Jean-Michel
fourgousse on a jamais donné on n'a
jamais validé un projet on veut au
contraire avoir un opérateur et qui nous
garantit ce plein de choses aujourd'hui
les garanties n'étant pas là il est hors
de question que on continue à débattre
on va travailler on va conduire à
travailler mais avec je dire plus de
temps moi je veux dire que le que le ski
d'homme se fasse ou se fasse pas il va
falloir aussi que on regarde l'équilibre
de nos comptes et les opposants au ski
d'homes de se satisfaire de la situation
au parti socialistes notamment pour la
section et l'encourtoise on évoque une
prise de conscience de la réalité mais
on se dit aussi méfiant je l'ai ne veut
pas dire abandonné le collectif des amis
de la revanche partage ce point de vue
je suis content que Monsieur le Maire
est enfin reconnu que nos arguments sont
bons ce projet n'est pas équilibré au
départ il est mal ficelé il est
abandonné il est pas encore il n'est
seulement gelé évidemment qu'un projet
de mesurer est difficile à équilibrer
c'était le cas du projet de SnowWorld si
nous avons un projet plus humble qui
permet simplement d'accéder à la colline
de de faciliter l'accès de créer des
chemins dans te retenir l'existant on
arrive à un projet qui est tout à fait
dans nos moyens quand on étudie budget
de la casquille évidemment 5 millions
c'est beaucoup évidemment 50 millions
c'est énorme mais avec quelques
prestations d'entretien il me semble
possible de permettre l'accès à tous de
la colline l'idée d'une piste de ski
couverte a déjà été évoquée à de
nombreuses reprises ces 30 dernières
années pour le moment aucun autre projet
n'est avancé sur la colline d'Élancourt
qui devrait donc rester encore quelques
temps en friche
un projet abandonné à un autre qui
pourrait être dévoilé dans quelques mois
cela concerne non pas la piste de ski
elle encourt mais Skywest à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux lancer voici 10
ans le centre commercial est aujourd'hui
quasiment vide à un échec pour les
promoteurs qui après avoir pensé le
transformer en un centre dédié au luxe à
bas prix réfléchissent maintenant à la
possibilité de revenir aux sources ils
l'ont dévoilé mercredi
rappelez-vous 2001 un centre commercial
portant le nom de fiesta devait sortir
de terre à Montigny-le-Bretonneux un
centre commercial novateur pour l'époque
dédiée aux loisirs finalement il n'en
sera rien à la place Skywest est
inauguré en grande pompe en 2005 cela se
veut un lieu tourné vers les enseignes
haut de gamme quelques années plus tard
les rideaux de la plupart des enseignes
sont baissés il reste encore le
locomotive UGC mais le centre est bien
triste le projet carré privé ouest dédié
au luxe à prix cassé est abandonné en
2013 un nouveau dossier serait sur les
rails même si c'est un peu trop tôt pour
l'officialiser pour le propriétaire
amerson on ne se cache plus vraiment oui
il y a un projet sur Skywest il y a
plusieurs agences qui travaillent
aujourd'hui sur ce projet de
développement on ne peut rien dire de
précis puisque il y a plusieurs pistes
étudiées mais je peux vous rassurer sur
le fait qu'il y a beaucoup de monde à
travailler sur la restructuration
globale de Skywest qui sera un projet en
tout cas complémentaire de l'espace
Saint-Quentin pour une peut-être
dynamiser cette ce belle édifice c'est
trop tôt d'annoncer tout de suite
loisirs culture mais en effet ça serait
intéressant de d'étudier cette
perspective là un projet donc qui n'est
pas sans rappeler le concept initial
fiesta un centre commercial tourné vers
les loisirs et l'offre culturel je crois
qu'on a perdu beaucoup de temps pour des
raisons de concurrence de rivalité et en
tout cas on revient à la base à
l'essentiel et aujourd'hui on se dirige
vers ce qui a toujours été finalement la
conception de Jean-Luc Solal à l'époque
c'est-à-dire faire un centre tourné vers
la culture et le loisirs le nouveau
Skywest devra trouver sa place parmi une
offre concurrentielle importante one
nation Paris qui vient par exemple
d'ouvrir ses portes au Clayes-sous-Bois
et qui cherchent encore sa clientèle on
se demande s'il y a pas justement des
surfaces commerciales un peu trop
nombreuses
c'est des questions qu'on peut se poser
il y a quand même des inquiétudes en
tant que chambres de commerce on peut
avoir que des inquiétudes si justement
ces centres de commerciaux ne se
développent pas
la société amersson veut encore rester
discrète tout juste sait-on qu'en ce
mois de novembre un salon professionnel
pourrait être le lieu de signature
d'accord pour de futurs enseignes
intéressés le projet complet pourrait
être dévoilé début 2015
et cette annonce officieuse d'un nouveau
projet vient rassurer donc les
exploitants du cinéma UGC cette dernière
locomotive du centre l'UGC qui célèbre
en ce moment c'est dix ans avec des
promotions pour des clients la soirée
anniversaire c'est dérouler mardi juste
ici c'est le verdicté tomber en fin de
journée jeudi à la cour d'assise de
Versailles Olivier ancien pompier
volontaire qui n'est de profession va
purger 13 ans de prison pour avoir
empoisonné et noyer son fils de 3 ans
après avoir appris la volonté de sa
femme de divorcer la Cour n'a pas retenu
l'après méditation et à estimer que le
discernement de l'accusé avait été
altéré au moment des faits l'avocat
général avait requis 20 ans de réclusion
à l'encontre de l'auteur d'un assassinat
qu'il décrit vengeur et égoïste
un nouveau plan de lutte contre le vol à
main mais est rentré en application dans
la grande couronne parisienne il sera
déployé dans le reste de la France c'est
très prochainement en quoi consiste ce
plan Anthony Rech
c'est policiers ont tenu parcours à pied
les allées de ce nouveau centre
commercial dans le cadre du plan anti
Vama veulent à marmer ce dispositif qui
a succédé au plan anti hold-up en 2013
prévoit un renforcement d'émissions de
surveillance des forces de l'ordre dans
les zones commerciales
c'est de mon conseil un prénom très
aussi avec des sociétés privées qui nous
est aussi beaucoup sur tout ce qui est
des marques hold-up braquage etc mais
bon ça fait une synergie tout le monde
est impliqué là-dedans donc on a des
acteurs autour de nous donc pour nous
c'est bien avec ce dispositif les
commerçants peuvent également dialoguer
avec un référent sur T un policier de
terrain qui a pour mission de permettre
aux commerçants d'améliorer les
protections autour de leur établissement
les commerçants souvent sont évidemment
un petit peu dans la routine chacun dans
sa propre routine pour sa sécurité ne
modifie pas les heures à laquelle il
transfère l'argent à la banque il ne
s'interroge pas trop sur les allées
venues du personnel par des portes
sécurisées ou pas par d'éventuelles le
système de badge sur leur système
d'alarme à des choses assez simples pour
nous mais qui ne sont pas leur métier
sur la circonscription de plaisir si
personne sont mobilisées 7 jours sur 7
le plan anti-volamar mais prévoit
également des opérations de sécurisation
menées avec les CRS et il sera appliqué
jusqu'au 15 janvier prochain depuis
septembre 2013 les vols à armés
constatées par la police nationale ont
augmenté de 40% dans les Yvelines
et la mise en place de ce plan n'a pas
empêché de malfaiteurs de braquer à
l'Intermarché de Magny-les-Hameaux
dimanche dernier peu après 6 heures les
quatre employés déjà présents ont été
menacés et séquestrés elle est voleurs
ne sont repartis qu'avec 600 euros
on continue à revenir sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité que nous avons traité cette
semaine dans le journal on passe à la
culture le festival international du
cours métrage de Paris c'est en ce
moment il souffle même ses 10 bougies et
pour l'occasion une nouvelle catégorie
voit le jour ça tourne en Île-de-France
va permettre de récompenser la jeune
création cinématographique de la région
300 films inscrits 64 sélectionnés 24
projections dans 10 salles il ne reste
maintenant plus que 8 courts métrages un
par département franciliens pour les
Yvelines le réalisateur s'appelle
Valentin Jolivot il est auteur de seuls
ensemble et vous allez découvrir la
bande-annonce
un mec normal
tu peux pas débarquer ici et tout
en l'air
seul ensemble un court-métrage que vous
pourrez découvrir ainsi que les autres
en compétition pour ça tourne en
Île-de-France ce samedi à 8 novembre à
partir de 18h15 au ciné 7 à Élancourt
son réalisateur Valentin Jolivot espère
bien sûr le soutien de son public lui
qui a développé le projet lors de cette
dernière année de formation à l'école
troisis à Élancourt justement on
l'écoute il était en plateau jeudi soir
ça a pris
7 8 mois environ presque presque une
année en fait à la rentrée on de l'école
on demande déjà de d'avoir une idée de
scénario donc il y a eu un scénario qui
a été déjà écrit et puis après on
travaille pendant quelques mois dessus
avec un script doctor donc là qui était
qui chargée de s'occuper de là où il y
avait des erreurs entre guillemets de
scénario de dramaturgie tout ça et puis
et puis une fois que c'était validé on
passait au tournage donc le tournage a
duré une semaine donc c'était très court
là aussi mais voilà et un mois et demi
avec la post-production montage et post
prod ça représente quoi justement de
défendre un projet comme ça et puis
éventuellement d'avoir une possibilité
de l'emporter bah ça représente
pression c'est déjà un plaisir qui soit
qui soit diffusé puisque beaucoup de
gens ne connaissent pas le court-métrage
voilà il y en a qui vont au cinéma pour
voir des longs des têtes d'affiches donc
c'est l'occasion aussi aux gens de
découvrir le court métrage et puis c'est
toujours un plaisir de montrer son
travail tout simplement
ce journal est terminé ce week-end sur
TVfil le 7 8 week-end de présenté par
Anthony Reich a retrouvé à partir de
18h30 vous allez découvrir la seconde
édition de good Yvelines manifestation
pour mettre en avant les produits locaux
une semaine d'animation prévue dans le
département c'est la fin de ce journal
donc je vous retrouve lundi 10 novembre
à 18h en direct très bon week-end
n'oubliez pas nos replay sur le site de
TVfil et puis également de les commenter
sur les réseaux sociaux